[Música]
crecemos y escuchamos durante toda
nuestra vida que los límites no existen
que soñemos ilimitadamente hasta el
cielo que cada vez que nos caemos nos
tenemos que levantar y seguir y seguir y
seguir sin parar de luchar incluso
escuchamos que si nosotros utilizamos la
palabra límites es sinónimo de
conformismo
si entramos al buscador de google y
ponemos la palabra el límite encontramos
n cantidad de imágenes con frases
inspiracionales que nos motivan vemos
frases como no limite sus retos reta tus
límites los límites son mentales tenés
que seguir adelante sin embargo si
entramos al diccionario de la real
academia española encontramos tres
definiciones nos vamos a centrar en la
última extremo que pueden alcanzar lo
físico y lo anímico ejemplo llegó al
límite de sus fuerzas entonces si
nosotros queremos analizar esta
definición tenemos que ir por partes
extremo si un extremo es lo último lo
más lejos a lo que se puede llegar sin
embargo para si quiere existir un
extremo en nuestras vidas tiene que
haber un inicio
un punto de partida el punto de partida
más importante para el ser humano solo
es uno y es el autoconocimiento
el autoconocimiento quién soy qué puedo
hacer por qué estoy aquí
qué debo hacer yo aquí en este mundo
cuál es mi propósito pero para responder
esas preguntas
necesitamos tener claro dos conceptos o
dos ideas depende de cómo lo queramos
ver en la autoestima y la asertividad la
autoestima es el motor de nuestras
conductas y la asertividad es tener
conciencia sobre esa conducta
una persona asertiva es una persona que
puede diferenciar el bien del mal
es una persona que tiene la idea clara
de cómo canalizar su enojo y convertirlo
en algo positivo
su furia llevarla a un deporte a una
actividad física una persona asertiva
también es la persona que tiene la
capacidad de auto perdonarse yo hoy en
día me considero una persona asertiva
fue un proceso que es parte de lo que
les estoy contando pero una persona
asertiva como les decía que tiene la
capacidad de auto perdonarse es la
persona que puede manejar cualquier
proceso en su vida nosotros a diario nos
damos duro nos ofendemos con nosotros
mismos a veces hasta nos insultamos
creemos que no somos capaces de lograr
cosas y eso lo único que crea es una
tristeza una depresión
entonces si somos personas asertivos y
que tenemos una autoestima correcta o en
el nivel correcto para poder lograr
cosas ese es el momento donde todo
inicia sin embargo muchas personas se
preguntan pero y yo como lo hago donde
comienzo cómo puedo auto conocerme con
esta pirámide podemos ver los aspectos
importantes al momento de tener que ver
de dónde o cómo comenzar
la autoestima es lo más importante eso
nos genera autoconocimiento
entonces si sabemos que necesitamos un
punto de partida para poder siquiera
llegar a ese extremo sabemos o podemos
entender que todo es parte de un proceso
a veces nosotros nos perdemos o nos
equivocamos porque se nos olvida que la
vida entera es un proceso sin importar
que estemos pasando nosotros en nuestras
vidas siempre hay procesos a veces un
proceso de tres pasos a veces un proceso
de 50 pasos pero todo en la vida es
parte de un proceso
las herramientas para que esto pueda
funcionar para que ustedes se puedan
auto conocer para que ustedes puedan ser
honestos con ustedes mismos para que
ustedes conozcan sus límites para que
sepan hasta dónde pueden llegar por sus
capacidades que pueden hacer cuando
conocen sus capacidades con mensaje
explotarlas sin desviar te manteniéndote
firme y logras hasta tres veces lo que
te lo que pudiste haber logrado cuando
estaba solamente soñando necesitadas
auto honestidad integridad respeto amor
propio fe en tus propias decisiones y lo
más importante necesitas tener auto
confianza la auto confianza te lleva al
auto entendimiento cuando confías en lo
que haces te da seguridad la seguridad
que no necesitas de nadie más cuando
confías en tus acciones logran entender
por qué está pasando lo que pasa
alrededor tuyo cuando confías en tus
acciones tener la posibilidad
de decidir
sí o no pero porque es tu decisión no
porque te están diciendo cómo decidir
y primer hoyo
sabemos que en este proceso del cual le
he contado termine en el extremo en lo
último me conozco sé quién soy soy
honesto conmigo mismo
me entiendo conozco mis límites y sé
hasta dónde puedo llegar sé de lo que
soy capaz de hacer y este es el momento
cuando yo voy a discernir sobre y por
mis acciones
este es el momento en el que ustedes
saben decir sí y aprenden a decir no
porque es súper difícil pero créanme por
experiencia se los digo no hay
sentimiento más agradable que decir no
cuando uno no quiere cuando uno no puede
es que vamos a ir desde lo más leve
vamos a ir al cine quería ir con
nosotros y ahí voy a estar en tu cama
constado y lo último que quería hacer es
levantarte pero ahí va a ir el cerebro
taca taca taca el corazoncito tucu tucu
tucu
dame un ratito solo déjame ver es que mi
mamá me dijo ya que va que el testamento
porque no va a ir al cine y solo estás
en tu cama costado porque no quiere ir
al cine
me ha pasado a los dos lados de la
historia pero ahora cuando sucede es no
comas no quiero ir con más gracias punto
y yo no me siento mal no les faltando el
respeto a nadie me invitaron al cine y
no quiero ir
eso a mí me da tranquilidad porque no
estoy mintiendo estoy diciendo la verdad
y me da tranquilidad y paz porque estoy
siendo honesto conmigo mismo y eso hasta
lo más serio
es que llegan a la oficina y yo estoy
bien yo soy ejemplo de recursos humanos
y me dicen es que tenemos que despedir a
fulano de tal hay no es que un anoeta el
taca taca taca taca taca taca pero uno
sabe que de verdad no está funcionando
entonces si vamos a tomar la decisión
usted ya no puede trabajar con nosotros
porque se le explica porque es una
motivación para seguir adelante
uno se va a la casa y se duerme
tranquilo
entonces primero yo
y lo último con lo que los dejo aquí
nosotros somos una familia somos una
comunidad somos honduras pero que no se
les olvide que para poder ser esa
comunidad
lo primero es soy yo soy límites soy yo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
y